i'm curious because uh when you first
started out and you did sean of the dead
and i
i understand this because my people
uh are descended from uh ireland
i'm 100 irish so i understand what
is called in the uk the tall poppy
syndrome where
it's something that's in british culture
where if someone's had
a lot of success people feel the need to
chop him down
when you first hit with sean of the dead
um not long afterwards there were people
in the uk who had the sentiment
simon peggs growing too big too fast is
that true
well i was i was aware that that might
so because sean was a was a as a was a
hit and and
you know we we received a certain amount
of attention i was
anticipating this being the case so um
in an interview i think with probably
the sun newspaper and they
and they accusingly said oh you're gonna
go off and go to hollywood now aren't
you like that's
some sort of treasonous criminal act you
know like i was gonna
cross some misty bridge at night and
never come home again
and i said quite i mean just
off the cuff i just said i'm not gonna
just leave and be in i don't know
mission impossible three
which was a film which didn't exist at
that time it was just mission impossible
too
and then about a month later jj abrams
called and said
hey do you want to be the mission
impossible three and i said yes i do
where's my plane ticket and uh
and that happened as well with what else
did it happen with there was another
thing that i
well probably star trek because i know
that you're a big sigh
i mean you've had this you you've had
this
run and i just because i've interviewed
you a bunch and i'm i'm familiar with
uh with your predilections
uh not all of them but you really do
i mean you idolized uh star trek and
then suddenly you're in
star trek it says go ahead and
they're in space this is this is what it
was the idol in our sitcom space which
is where we sort of began
there was a line from my character about
the the notion of certainty and the line
was as sure as eggs is eggs
as sure as every odd-numbered star trek
movie is [ __ ]
and then you jump forward like maybe 15
years and i'm writing star trek
13. it was a self-fulfilling prophecy
i do feel i do feel that in a previous
lifetime
um and not that you don't deserve
success because you certainly do but in
a previous lifetime
you did something very heroic and
wonderful
because it feels to me that you're
constantly working on
projects or being able to join projects
that you would have been huge
a huge fan of you'd have been in line to
see that star trek movie
you'd have been in in line to see
mission impossible
if you weren't in them absolutely
it's true and it's very strange now it's
a lovely thing
and i've i'm never not blown away by
that sort of circularity of
the stuff that i enjoyed as a kid the
the you know
whether it be the films of spielberg who
i ended up working with or being into
something like star wars or star trek
and
and getting to participate in that it's
been a real treat you know and i'm here
now on the
you know we're making mission impossible
seven and uh we're not it's not called
that
i don't know what it's called yet but
it's certainly not mission impossible
seven sorry
um but we're here doing that and it's
very exciting
but behind you you can't see this but
lawyers are closing in on you
tom cruise is just like this with a gun
just
just a little red dot on your head and
then down